as we continue on this breaking news 9
tonight on Hannity now yesterday I sat
down with one of the first otters and
advisor to the president Ivanka Trump
for an exclusive interview I did ask
Ivanka how she felt about the mainstream
media and their vicious unprecedented
attacks on her her father the entire
Trump family take a look it was
interesting Jimmy Carter even said that
he'd never witnessed any president take
as much heat as your dad but also the
family I mean you've been attacked
Milani has been attacked the little
brother's been attacked Don and Eric I
don't care about them it's just personal
and mean you feel it I be disingenuous
if I didn't say it didn't affect me I
think though you know at the end of the
day the real people suffering in this
country are not me and my family we can
take it it's the millions of Americans
we saw across this country who are
addicted to opioids or have lost a child
to opioid abuse who have lost their jobs
because their industry can no longer be
competitive I mean there there are
people who are really suffering and so
you know if we have to take a few body
blows and advocating for those men and
women I think everyone in my family and
everyone in this administration is
honored to do it that's a great answer I
believe it or not in this little
business I'm in I take a few hits too
more than my fair share I want to ask
you about this and this was interesting
I thought this was a very important
point one of my biggest complaints about
people in DC is they're not there to
serve they don't work hard enough for
the people that that elected them or put
them there
if you work in the house that your dad
now lives in to me I think that's one of
the great honors in in life that you you
have the opportunity I also my father
the day I don't get chills walking into
the White House every day every day
there's a sense of awe as to what has
transpired and what has been
accomplished in those halls and you
should always remember it and she should
always feel it and you should always
deeply respect it but ya know Washington
is a complicated place bloodsport you
know I I care a lot about ideas I care
much less than this maybe makes me a
pragmatist but I care less about who
came up with the idea who originated the
idea and more about the idea itself and
and good ideas and and and ideas that
support this country and and its
citizens you know it's a but it's it's a
complicated City I actually I was joking
earlier today that you leave Washington
and you feel rejuvenated I don't go
hunting with my brothers
yeah I'm not a good hunter at all you're
not say I have a good shot at least tell
me it's it's beginner's luck
you said something the other day and I
thought this should be the attitude of
anybody that serves in any
administration that it's a team that
it's your father that got elected yes
and that it's his agenda and we're there
to serve him so he can serve people 100%
I mean he was elected by the American
people to the privilege of serving this
great country I was not I am there to
support the agenda and Aaron
that I feel that I can add value and
then I'm passionate about and where
we're aligned
doesn't mean I'm not my own person that
I don't share my opinion but I'm also
cognizant that he's given me the
privilege to think about how I can
remove barriers particularly when I
think about women entrepreneurs women in
the workforce supporting the American
family job creation these are things I'm
deeply passionate about workforce
development skills training so I I feel
blessed and I feel very lucky he's given
me the opportunity to do that but you
know people who make it about themselves
in their own agenda you know there's a
lot of opportunism in Washington it's
everyone everyone coos trees and service
of the President and look as an American
I think we all have to be lending our
voice to the discussions that matter in
this country and we all have to want to
have a seat at the table in areas where
we agree you can always find areas of
difference that's easy but in areas of
agreement as an American I feel like
it's my duty to see if I can be helpful
and serve which more people had that
attitude to serve